what is going on everybody and welcome
to
the first episode in the uh what i'm
going to call
generative python transformers
so um as many of you guys probably know
uh you know the gpt model and
transformers in general are very good at
natural language and one of the things
that i did a very long time ago
uh back then was with i believe it was
lstms
um was can we make uh python learn
to write uh convincing python code
and the answer was you know at a quick
glance yes you could
but this code would not actually run it
was it was not
valid code in any way so now the
question would be
could we use transformers to do so
because we definitely know
transformers have a much much deeper
understanding of language more so than
say an lstm network you know structure
can
uh and then we also know that
transformers
can take into context very very long
context so we're talking
1 000 2 000 plus
tokens of context so a token in most
cases is going to be a
um a sub string of a word
so you know like access token you know
it's probably going to be i don't know
ack s
talk n right so access token becomes
four unique tokens let's say
anyway um don't want to get too deep
into the weeds on that right now but
it was so access token wouldn't be like
one token
but you would be able to go back
historically probably
hundreds of words of code and so you're
much more likely to
write coherent code i think not really
sure but
it is something i'm curious about so
step one to
solving this problem or just
experimenting with this problem
is to get a lot of python files
so the first order of business is and
just as a quick
side note uh if you've not uh if you're
not aware
there is chat with char which is
charlotte which is one of the latest
chat bots using the
uh dilo gpt model
um so go there follow talk to her you
can dmr just understand
i can see the dms it's my account so
let's keep it you know let's keep it pg
let's not creep out me
okay anyway so so coming over to search
um so just just just
as an example we have just of the python
programming language
there are 1.2 million repository results
so when we go to train a model it's like
a transformer model we have to decide in
well any model you have to decide what
is your input what is your output we
already know the input to this
style of model is going to be um
these encoded tokens now and those
encoded tokens will map
to strings or substrings of text usually
substrings of
of words like i just showed with like
access token for example
so that's going to be the input so the
input you can think of it as
we're going to literally input code it's
just going to be encoded code
the output it's unclear what what do we
actually want this model to output so
there's a there's a few things that we
can do we can either
you know you can input um you know you
can input your code
up to a specific line like right before
line break and then have the model
predict
the next line of code you could have the
model predict
every time you type in a full word or
even begin typing at all
it just continuously predicts the next
uh word or the next
maybe three five tokens something like
that
um you could have it predict um
let's say you could do like sub word
then up to the next line or even you
could have it predict the next
maybe block of code even so there's
there's a ton of stuff that we can do
but no matter what we decide we want to
do there that's just going to be trial
and error figure out what works
no matter what we decide we want to do
pro
we need a lot of code and there's no
better place for
uh for for github code than or for
python code that i could think of than
github
and so we have 1.2 million and that
would mean that we would in theory be
able to input like if there's hundreds
like i say we we input a line and then
align with context and then expect some
output
we should in theory be able to have
probably hundreds of
of samples per python repository that we
find some of these repositories are
going to be very simple i'm sure
uh and then some are going to be you
know extensive and probably have
not hundreds but probably thousands so
we're at least looking at like 100
million plus
is just a quick low end estimate my
guess is there's probably more like
um a billion i guess
it's probably a huge number so um
regardless we need a lot of python code
so the first step
is to get it off of um off of github
and then the only other tab i have here
is i couldn't decide how i was going to
clone these
um and i've never done like a get clone
into
a different directory than what you're
calling get uh you know get clone in but
apparently you can just have
a folder name and that works so um
that was the only other tab that i got
open for us so let's get back over here
so basically
on github i left a couple of notes you
can go to github.com
settings tokens to get a token it's
unclear to me if you actually need
tokens to use the search api
i i don't think you probably do and the
only reason i'm using
i'm going to be using this pi github the
only reason we're doing that as opposed
to just curl the
api url is for pagination
so um we want to be able to easily
paginate we could code in the pagination
obviously um i just don't feel like it
so
anyway we're going to use pi github but
you could do this with some other
language and get by
so once we have and this just basically
confirms that i have the user
i just copy and pasted the token into
token.txt so i don't have to worry about
accidentally showing
my token so
um so the way that this works
is essentially all you have to do and i
am going to
take the something from the docs here
you can query now
github with the following so you can say
result equals g for
this is just that github api uh search
repositories and then you have a query
now the query um can be
bruh it can be a whole bunch of things
in our case what we want probably
is to say and i believe it's like
language call yeah
so we would want maybe language colon uh
python
so then you get um a result and like
literally that's all we're gonna query
we're just looking for
anything in the language of python we
could get way more specific if we wanted
to
and later on you probably will want to
so again
it doesn't really matter where end
objective is right now
we just want a lot of python code to
train the model and then you would
probably fine tune that model
to flask or
django or tensorflow or pi torch and get
it
very very specific because chances are
those specific libraries have things
that are very unique to them so like for
example if you're working with flask
um you know probably many of your
functions are actually going to have
decorators
in front of them whereas the average
python code does it have a decorator
before each function
uh no so um so yeah things are going to
vary
by uh you know what specific use case
you're using them in so
and my guess is the transformer you
could train a transformer to know
to to recognize is this django code is
this flask code and so on
it's unlikely out of the gate that it
will do that really well but who knows
so uh so we have our query we have our
result um
and then this gives us like an object i
want to say we can just uh let's go
ahead and
print result let's just make sure this
works
right so so what we get is this like
paginated list object so
i think what i can say is result
let's print dir that's all
if we have to i'll check the
documentation but um
so total count so maybe that's one thing
that we want to check out so we could
say
uh print result dot tot what is it total
count
uh print result total count
a thousand so um so one of the
first things that we're gonna have a
problem with is
um right this should be like 1.2 million
not a thousand but no surprise the api
is not going to return to us
easily 1.2 million 1.2 million results
now what we can do i want to say we can
iterate over this and i believe it
handles the pagination for us so
for uh repository
repository in result uh
print dir let's just get print der
repository
uh we'll do one quick break
oh my gosh should i really do that
oh man that's embarrassing um okay so
then this gives us
um a bunch of the so we'd probably want
the git url
so we could grab it so for example let's
do
print f
uh git dot
url and that's what we'll do to get
clone um
subscribers see if there's anything else
i really want uh
quickly here probably not i mean that's
probably all we need
right out of the gate let's go ahead and
make sure that works
oops man
what was it get underscore url i already
forgot what the answer or that was
yeah my brain's not working today huh
repository
dot get url i don't remember if it was
get underscore you i guess it was
right so github.com so that's our get
url
so we can either grab it from that or we
could get it from oh what we actually
really want is probably the clone url
because we're gonna
what would be the difference between the
dunder um
that like internal um and then the
regular
i don't know that's a great question
great question harrison let's see
um let's stop doing this
we can we'll keep the total result
because i'm curious
i'll save print that out i thought we
okay so i guess it's some sort of object
still
and then we have this so then we could
grab it from there
okay so anyway awesome so now um
so the first problem that we have
besides so we got the urls now
the next problem that we have is our
query is just way too big
so i did some poking around prior to
this because i knew this was going to be
a problem
and essentially we can do
quite a few things uh to the query here
so
first off um
i wonder if i still have the
no well anyway uh you
in the search query you you have options
such as
um you can come here and so besides
specif obviously you know your query is
going to contain
things like and you could do the same
thing in the search bar on the website
i'm pretty sure
so you've got things like you know what
are you looking for so
say you could do django space and then
you could say
lang
my brain is fried today for some reason
python
um and then finally you can say created
and this can be a whole bunch of things
you could say it's created and then it's
like year month day so you could say
2021
so this would be created after 2021
um 0401 so created after april 1st 2021
you can also do which is what we're
gonna do
uh arrange so we're gonna say 2021
to 2021.0402
now there might be some days where
you have a thousand um and that's okay
uh we'll just have to sacrifice some i
don't think
we can go deeper like into the hours
minute seconds i don't think that's an
option
so let's go ahead and uh comment that
out i think we'll just go forward with
this query right here
uh that's fine oh my gosh
seriously there's 458 django
is that serious did we do something
wrong like
i'm having a hard time believing there's
458 django repositories
um in a single day
but okay let's let's cheat oh
dang it um
oh okay um i think
i really thought that was gonna be
totally acceptable i'm kind of surprised
that um
i'm surprised how god am i doing
something wrong here
result query language python
i feel like i'm doing something wrong
language
python um
let's go pi opengl we gotta do something
that okay thank
god we need we need something that is
like super
rarely used uh apparently uh
so let's switch to so this will be about
a year okay so in a year
we get nine i wanted to make sure the
logic is working
um okay so it is working which is oh my
god
create created is the project was
created so we're not even talking about
you could also search like modified and
all these other things but
i can't believe that there's a thousand
django projects a day
what about flask uh let's go back to
2021 flask is a little less popular
there we go
cool okay so then if we do a whole month
of flask what do we get
a thousand okay i just again i just want
to make sure this logic is working
before we go too deep um okay so
now what i want to do is where are we
working so okay so the next thing that
we want to do is we want to
cycle through the dates so let's go to
copy pasta
uh to and we're going to say and if
yeah for i just want to uh
testing date cycle i just want something
to test something in real quick so we're
going to import
time we're going to import uh date time
and i think that's everything we need so
we're going to say start
actually we'll say end time equals time
dot
time and let me come over here and
uh yeah
give me action yeah we'll take this
whoops
uh we'll make this an f string and then
this becomes uh
created so this would be we'll call a
start time i know it doesn't exist yet
it will
momentarily uh end
time so then uh start time will be
time actually will be end time minus
80 86 400 that's the number of seconds
in a day
uh okay
now we need to convert these to
their respective uh date time
objects and i don't have that memorized
actually what we need to do from
from date time import date time
and the thing that we want here is
this copy
uh paste so um
start time end time and then
start time end time i guess we'll do i'm
trying to think here now
um i'm trying to decide how i want to do
this
uh we would say like uh start time
string equals
this start time then we'll do the exact
same thing for the end time string
end time string
and then we will do um
end time minus equals 86 400
start time minus equals 86
400 and then finally
for i n range let's just do like five of
these
uh tab this over
do this cut that come here pasta
uh actually we need to do this
underneath here
and what we want to say is we will
do start time string
end time string run that
oh query
dummy cool
so what this gives us is and today is at
least when i'm recording this april 10th
which
it might be a long time before you'll
see this the reason why videos are being
like
dated back is i can't share the fact
that i have the dgx station
so soon though soon in a few days videos
will start flowing
um so um
okay so what we have is we've got april
10th here
uh so basically we're going to search
the range of april 9th to april 10th and
then the next
time the next search will be april 8th
to april 9th and so on
so that's how we're going to get around
this thousand limit so that gives us
uh you know one a day so
350 000 uh searches a year
provided we don't hit some error with
github i mean it's totally possible that
they're gonna
they're gonna throttle us uh well we'll
see what happens when we get there
um they shouldn't i mean i think these
are pretty light requests but
who knows um
i've been dealing with the twitter api
did i mention chat with shar
um anyway um
so anyway yeah the twitter api i hate
that api
it's so restrictive it's so restrictive
anyway coming back over here so what
we're going to do is
we'll take this come over here we're
going to import this we need to grab
these starting values
copy pasta
uh query
so this is the stuff that will be in our
loop
and we're gonna i'm going to do my best
to break things so we're not like
going crazy on the uh on the api too
fast
uh because i'm pretty sure every pageant
what have i done
hopefully i didn't screw up my recording
i'm pretty sure um
every pagination would be is like a new
call because you're gonna say it's gonna
give you page one then you're gonna say
okay give me page two now
so every single pagination is a call and
i forget how many items are actually on
each page probably 100 to 200
so in that case um every call
is going to be a new api call and
yeah so i just want to make sure we
don't wind up getting banned
so uh coming back over here um
so we've got our start end time and then
we build the query
so we'll just do this copy paste
and let's just do
two and we'll do three
and uh so that gives us our query we
don't need that we're gonna cut that
we're gonna go over here
block that out and then
we're just going to comment this out for
now
and just see if this um
if this works so we'll get a total count
and again we're not i don't want to
search
well i guess we could leave flask just
so we can see the different numbers
okay cool wow that's fast
we're totally gonna get banned okay um
so maybe we'll institute some weights or
something
i don't know um so now that we have that
we can then
um i think we're going to run that in
the
in a terminal rather than sublime text
it's probably started getting kind of
laggy
python3 one beginning.pie
didn't we ask to iterate
did i not ask to iterate oh no we do oh
i just set one and then break
cool it's there yeah blind boy
there it is okay so once we've done that
um hmm
there's one more possible thing we might
want to
do um what was do we print are we still
printing dur
repository no uh let's go ahead and do
that real quick so
as an expert at building data sets
uh one of the regrets that you usually
have is not collecting
all of the data you could possibly need
uh and then regretting it later
so um
uh what what we want to check for
um isn't is there something like tags
maybe
tags url i'm not sure what that means um
like what is it called like if we go
to let's just go to a repo so all
algorith all algorithms
implemented in python um
yeah i kind of want to grab these
tags these are tags right or maybe top
topics let's see if either of those
things show up here
so you got tags there there is no topics
i'm just going to whoops
let's let's grab the tags so the reason
why i want to do this is
later if you wanted to become very
specific into using tensorflow or django
or whatever
this is so you don't have to go back and
rerun all this code for like some very
specific
task you would already have it um
let's just see what it looks like but
tag url see like everybody has like many
tags
so i don't think that's going to work
let's just run this real quick
in here
really what was i just looking at then
full
hold on let's see here i think it was
right here yeah what was this
oh tags uh url
what is
i'm not sure we're gonna we're probably
gonna leave that behind for now
um
yeah i'm just i'm not seeing anything
like super obvious here as far
as as that and
unless we start hitting like uh
throttling things
i'm not going to worry about it um it
looks like we can pull pretty quickly
uh and really it's the the transfer
learn and the fine tune like this
you won't need nearly as much data you
probably don't even have to go you know
throughout
all of time to get it get it uh okay so
now the last thing that we'll do is
let's see
if this works uh we'll call it repos
i think that's fine uh and then finally
moment of truth import os
um
i don't actually know if there's like a
great way using this github api to just
clone the repo
it would be nice can we let's see
repository
for repository we are printing dur
repository
right that's what this is can we just
clone it
clone url i don't see
clone i mean that would be like a really
obvious like dot clone and then you'd
specify the path
right like that would be maybe get
download
i don't think so though
why would not that be a thing in uh
whatever um
github i have to google this there's
just i
i'm having a really i'll use os to do it
but
um let's see pi github pi github
clone i don't know i don't know what to
call it
create clone and push to github
i'm not sure what pi get 2 is that's not
what i wanted
okay well let's just do the os call i
think that'll be fine
import os uh we'll come down here uh
oh is that system and we're going to run
git
clone i think we can get away with an f
string here git clone
and then it is the repository.cloneurl
and then finally we want it in repos
right repos
ah i don't think it's gonna work but
let's see what happens
good luck everybody
repos already exists and it's not ah
i see i see i already know what happened
so this is probably just the base coat
yeah
why why why you do that to me
okay so we
we could just do repo slash and then the
name
that would be acceptable uh does this
have
do we already i can't even remember did
we are we already printing out the name
not yet i'm sure there's a name
attribute here
name cool
so we'll do that um so first we will
delete repos there hopefully we don't
have to like make this directory
here either we're gonna find that out
quickly
uh re so it'll be repo slash and then
uh repository.name
that's where we want it to go so we'll
go ahead and run that save
redo it whoops
please work
what
are you all called man
so okay it has to be the name slash i
guess
and i mean that makes sense why is this
doing it twice
it almost looks like for the same
like these two are
okay uh we'll do author
and then the name and we're still going
to have an error with that one author
which is super frustrating but
um that's okay so surely there is author
here
surely i said what
how is there not author uh how about
user
oh my gosh
uh okay owner now
repos repository so it'll be repos
slash owner
slash repository name okay
let's try that again so we come over
[Music]
here oh
repository repository
dot owner
i lost my terminal it's gone it's gone
forever
there's no finding it again uh python
three one beginning
oh got a sentence are you kidding me
[Laughter]
why who's the flask python language so
we got repos
nothing got created repo slash
repository owner
i wonder if that's like a url or
something uh print
uh repository.owner
owner
why are you guys doing this to me why
are you doing this to me
owner so maybe owner.login maybe is
going to be the
the name of the game then log in
oops yes so
owner and then we'll say dot login
save that bring this back
just work
okay please please
i don't i just i don't like it let's see
app.pie
looking good looking good
uh repose this one
cool okay okay so these are just flask
obviously um but we're off to a decent
start
so the next thing i would do is you know
we just we would just remove flask
so we would do that and then
save that um
maybe every day you might consider
sleeping
it might be wise um it's unclear to me
uh how heavy-handed github is going to
be
i've eventually i guess i'll find out um
but yeah so here we go we're going to
just clone a thousand so we'll see what
happens
if we're hitting any errors i mean i'm
not seeing
i'm not seeing anything bad yet
eventually
we're surely going to get smacked by uh
whoops i'm not in the right
where are we repos i mean we are we are
beginning
quite the collection here so um
i'm just gonna keep building this
collection uh this is only three days
worth but it'll be three thousand
repositories unless we're already kicked
off
no just doing stuff um
and then yeah i'll just look from there
i'll just see how much i can pull i'll
let you know
uh if they throttle me from there
it probably in the next video i guess
we'll do
probably the data set building so it'll
be it would be like an os
walk through the repos directory through
every single python file
and then um
uh b build the data set that way i'll
i'll spend some time kind of trying to
consider
how i want the very first rendition of
this to go
um because it's either the next word or
maybe finish the line of code most
likely that's going to be the
most successful so i don't know i just
i'll have to think on it how
how i'll build the data set like most
language models with
transformers in general you can train it
to just
even just predict the very next word and
then
from there transfer to a whole bunch of
other tasks or you could have it finish
the sentence
or predict the next sentence it doesn't
really matter
all that much what the initial trained
task is you're just simply training it
and it's
you know they're referred to as
unsupervised language models because
they just kind of figure it out and then
from there you can transfer it to do all
kinds of things
like question answering or like a
chatbot example that we have or
even regression dat i mean you can do
everything so
uh anyway it looks like we're off to
we're tuned fine i thought maybe if i
talked long enough we'd get smacked by
github but
it doesn't appear like like we have been
so
cool so that's all for now uh if you've
got questions comments suggestions
concerns whatever feel free to leave
those below
again uh if you want to talk to our
latest transformer chat bot it's
literally twitter.com
chat with shar go uh try to
break the code um anyways that's all for
now thanks for watching and i will see
you guys
in another video
you